hello to reach c'était un jeune mûri
pour dire que je suis sur halo reach et
sa commande très bien cette vidéo que je
fais tout simplement pas une vidéo phone
ou coin live faith rage commenté rien à
perdre même si chose la peur c'est vrai
ben en fait c'est juste bon déjà je
découvre un peu le jeu avec vous c'est
juste pour presque je tenais à faire une
[ __ ] de vidéos pour vous remercier
vous qui êtes maintenant quarante mille
donc sur ces 41 quand même pas mal
d'actifs
j'espère alors lui l'arrêt à kousseri
j'ai par contre chez a très bien compris
leur gardien mais il a très bien et
c'est bien au frais salut il est où le
bâton et cédé qu'au bon alors en tout
cas qu'est-ce que je terminerais déjà
bonjour j'avais oublié qu'ils avaient la
caméra juste la f1 est en fait
normalement mon accréditation devrait
être un peu mieux étant donné qu'il ya
un fond vert juste ici donc bon voilà
c'est ça c'est ça de gagner ça te fait
mais ouais mais je pense que fin
j'espère vraiment que qu'est ce que je
raconte je suis à fond dans le jeu je
dis n'importe quoi et lui gelé ou une
aide mais ces dames on va sur body bag
merde à temps non non non non non
membres maroc et pizzas et oui donc je
voulais vraiment tous et toutes by mahi
mahi américaine a exprimé tout et tous
vous remercier pour 1 bat pour pour tous
vos messages encore toutes vos idées
tout votre soutien et tout ça que je
reçois quotidiennement dans ma boîte de
réception youtube grâce à internet et et
je dois dire que c'est assez énorme que
vous êtes vraiment au bon ces temps ci
je suis un petit peu fatigué et c'est
pour ça que je vais pas sortir
énormément de vidéos vivement les
vacances j'ai envie de vous dire pour
recharger les batteries
mais à mais où est vraiment je trouvais
ça important de vous de vous remercier
parce que quand même 40 mille abonnés
vous imaginez 40000 ça veut dire que
dans ma rue on tient même pas tous c'est
ça qui je trouve incroyable là pourquoi
ça fait ça qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc début la partie changement d'autres
je sais pas et ouais je voulais vraiment
dire je trouve ça je trouve ça fou
imaginez on peut presque remplir un
stade quoiqu'à rempile à un stade
shippagan stade m'intrigue important et
c'est assez énorme bon même si sûr
entre vous doivent avoir trempé qui sont
réellement actifs et qui regarde
vraiment toutes mes vidéos et quoi ou
quoi mais ouais mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose de de bien et là je
roulerai ce qui se passe si c'est que ce
bordel là ça change d'autant fait tout
témoin cette base sur l oaba oui ça
change et d'autres très bien très bien
jeudi c'est c'est eh c'est vraiment
incroyable écoutez je pense que pour ses
48 l'abonné au niveau des vidéos
je vais tout simplement je passe en
anglais en fait c'est ça le truc parce
que normand wii ce jeu semble ou pas
même s'ils ont dit ah oui non merci ont
quand même été cadre d'accords excuse
moi
excuse moi je nomme encore [ __ ] c'est
une blague les gens alors on va mettre
ça en accéléré avons aussi c'est parti
chargement léandri ce que je pourrais
faire en attendant ok brad et des
champions de vera bon exemple sur les
décodeurs comme ça la sauvagerie de dos
de suite en plus amer un petit peu long
long long tête ces longues langlement
non le monde je chantais la mer longues
jambes on s'appelait ton pseudo était
étrange comme un boomerang au second il
boomerang est ok alors retournons donc
c'est parti on continue la vidéo tous
ensemble évidemment je ne vais pas là
continuer seul et c'est ça aussi un truc
que je voulais me dire qu'à c'est fou
quand on fait une vidéo
c'est que j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes à côté de moi avec moi dans la
salle avec moi dans ma chambre la
présence est à côté de moi et si présent
et c'est assez c'est assez
ça c'est marrant parce que du coup
hausse vous savez bon parler tout seul
devant un écran soit complètement débile
et c'est pour ça que tous les youtube
heures je pense faut un peu comme si
vous étiez avec nous quand on fait une
vidéo et c'est ça qui est super marrant
fait qu'on fait des vidéos est et ouest
l'un vous dire au cas où il y en a qui
savent pas et cette partie a
complètement fait le [ __ ] c'est la fin
olala falloir que j'en fasse une et ben
on va enchaîner missionnaire on va
enchaîner n'y a pas de souci je vais
j'ai enlevé mon ensuite en excluant
exclusivité totale je vais mettre une
musique un peu genre sexy derrière
attention c'est parti
[Musique]
rap et sébastien petit accroc stèle mais
enfin bon les gens écoutent et jaja même
en étant fatigué comme adecco n'est pas
mal et ça je trouve ça assez fou donc
alors aussi je voulais parler de
qu'est-ce que je vais faire avec
l'argent du partenariat parce que je
sais c'est quelque chose de très tabou
sur youtube c'est clair on peut pas dire
le contraire en soit c'est vraiment très
tabou attendait parce que juste avant
avant de parler de ça j'aimerais bien
savoir comment on fait pour relancer une
partie
adacore savoir ceux de recherche bon bah
écoutez c'est super donc je disais oui
avec l'argent des partenariats qu'est ce
que je compte faire
je compte en fait acheter déjà je vous
le dis sincèrement je vais faire environ
33 grecque et quelques marques d'aucy
évidemment je dois justement c'est tout
l'inversé en fait je ne vais vraiment
absolument pas acheté de trucs qui n'ont
pas de rapport avec les vidéos c'est à
dire que si je m'achète un grec
eh bien je devrais le manger pendant un
fait ce commentaire et voiliers et je
l'appellerai grec arrive hoyé ou kebabs
t'arrive nan je rigole
non mais vraiment je je je compte
vraiment acheté par exemple pour mon pc
qui n'en peut plus qui fait un bruit de
merde et je peux pas faire des vidéos
sur bf3 sur des jeux gourmands pc et je
remarque une classe pour voir son vélo
ce serait l'oubli
ce sera un peu mieux et oui donc je
pense acheter par exemple un processeur
une carte mère une alim ou des choses
comme ça je sais pas encore comment je
vais toucher écouter souffle et je vous
dirai je vous cache pas que ça pourra
peut-être vous impressionner ou quoi
ne croyez pas que j'ai touché une mine
d'or du style 3000 euros on découvrait
par sa non plus mais là où je risque de
toucher quoi je vais vous dire des
chiffres je vous dirai dans une
prochaine vidéo je pense que j'aurais
touché je touche milieu février environ
l'argent du partenariat
on va écouter moi y'a pas de soucis je
suis vraiment ouvert sur ça je peux vous
dire et tout quoi il ya vraiment aucun
souci
sachant que là avec avec la première
paye parce qu'en fait ça avec vous et au
bon se connaissent pas au bon c'est pas
super je vous vous dis davance mais
vraiment away je compte
je compte acheter vraiment que des
choses en rapport avec les vidéos par
exemple des jeux bon fond
et amédée detreaux granger oulaï à un
vote là dedans c'est que ce bordel mais
un wedge et composants d'aidé jo jeu des
trucs en rapport avec les vidéos avec la
première fois et je compte littéralement
vous refaire mon ordi et d'ouvriers et
payer des trucs vraiment
concentré âgé que de la merde tu
m'énerves toi la baule et à
l'incertitude est ok donc je dirais que
la première page je compte m'acheter moi
tout ce qu'il faut et tout pour niveau
matos vidéos et tout le bordel avec la
seconde paye je compte faire un peu ou
prou gbagbo fait gagner
nick pense à lui au matin les matchs
argile bouse 12 12
ok j'arrête de faire les allusions à
cortex prendre d'autres 30 mai ok bon
alors on va on va essayer de tuer des
gens il ya du monde il ya beaucoup de
moyens aux commandes c'est énormissime
attention oui vous bougez tibo'z profite
boss double field double fed
alors mr bah non c'est le mec des amants
il a tous les kids et mais serait ce
serait dommage donc je vous dirais
vraiment combien je vais gagner mais ce
sera je sais pas encore mais croyez pas
que je gagne 3000 euros je vous dis
davance mais ouais donc je vous dis avec
la première fois je vais acheter tout ce
qu'il faut pour les vidéos avec la
deuxième chose des concours et je ferai
sûrement bas un concours par mois un
concours par pay en fait tout simplement
parce que là en fait c'est compliqué là
je vais toucher pour en fait octobre
novembre décembre et lamy le février bas
c'est là que je vais toucher pour
tellement de décembre donc ensuite je
pense milieu marche toucherait pour
janvier à mai lieu en avril pour envoyer
ça un peu en décalé mais à 2
ok les mains mais en tout cas j'espère
que ce petit système de remettre une
certaine un certain pourcentage de
grâce à vous tout simplement ben dans
des concours ce à quoi je pense je pense
que vous en pensez mais je pense que je
le corps et est élu voilà en attendant l
hommisme les impressions c'est vraiment
un call of futuriste qui est tout
simplement et
enormissime voilà je voulais faire un
peu le jeu est en mode e non mais c'est
manqué voulez vous avez pu voir je sais
pas pourquoi je décris ce que je suis en
train de faire alors là je marche je
coure j'arrive je vais monter à
montheron miens de son genre alors
attention je vais essayer tout
simplement de viser la tête afin de
jouer par action comics et de kehl où je
faisais mon fils la tête
chaque team en rêvait ça c'est le genre
de commentaire attention c'était un
petit bonhomme bleu comme lui et ben va
te pendre mon gars tu es pas de commun
entre tous
olalala mais quelques coups de crosse
tous en tout cas elle est vraiment sympa
mais elle oublie james ça change du
colloque qui aura vraiment pas à partie
un mec va sur vous et qui fait
[Musique]
ok donc aux comptines et au continuo
continuons dé chaud cacao alors ouverte
où peuvent être les ennemis qui selon ce
barème observé que je vais vous parler
d'un problème que j'ai un bon ça c'est
au parquet ce matin donc c'est bien jean
confirme avis dans les commentaires et
que c'est pas plus mal
mais c'est à oui ça qui sert beaucoup
servi à grenade - mais c'est un truc en
fait qui fait que tout ce merdier mort
qui fait qu'en fait je rougis vachement
s'est déjà couché dans une situation
particulière je me mets à rougir mais
vraiment je rougis vraiment où la caméra
parce qu'une batterie sa croupe excusez
moi mais vraiment je me met vraiment à
rougir comme il faut quoi et je sais pas
s'il ya beaucoup de gens entrent ou qui
enregistre par exemple juste le fait
qu'un prof m'interroge par exemple et je
sache vraiment pas quoi répondre et
qu'un groupe blanc dans toute la salle
et tout le monde attend que je réponde
je mette à rougir comme un con et c'est
un truc c'est vraiment énorme alors
pourtant là je raconte plein de
conneries quoi je rougis pas mais c'est
un truc j'ai pas à l'ailé rougissement
fatale les rugissements de culture ou
non non non c'est mieux vraiment c'est
ça c'est fou et j'avoue je bouge pas ch
mon fils dont ceux pour ceux qui me
verront la période sus que l'année
prochaine
car oui j'ai honte honte parce que c'est
un pétard est vraiment malade au 20 mai
castille-la-manche king c'est vraiment
un truc hyper stylé avec des des filles
plutôt mineures et pas mal de jeux et un
monde n'est pas possible et une musique
d'ambiance par une musique derrière qui
tourne en fond la soul music sécheresse
que le sait mais c'est assez épique mais
à sachez que c'est vraiment un truc
génial et que l'année prochaine où tout
allait bien pour le but vide alba
tarawih gère bien et est que oui l'année
prochaine y aura pas mal de youtuber
genre warteck gens réputés diablos nos
jours c'est rien genre que jordan
maintes fois je pense qu'il retournera
genre moi
enfin voilà plein youtuber peut-être je
sais pas faire voilà la justice eut avec
qui j'ai déjà fait des jo - non non non
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir mais à mais
ouais c'est vraiment l'événement super
sympa je vous conseille vraiment de pour
ceux qui ont les moyens succès vers
paris ou même s'ils ne sont pas faire
paris au pire vous demandez pour votre
alors ça c'est un espèce de vos
recherches
je déteste ça m'énerve les preuves
physiques sont le meilleur moyen de
mettre des coups moi donc enfin bref et
oui donc je disais c'est vraiment un
truc vraiment super même si vous habitez
l'on essaie de vous procurer des places
un petit bus et le train et puis les
places mais place à qui twitte euros par
jour donc c'est le samedi mardi dans ce
mardi c'est quelque chose d'énorme
j'espère que vous serez [ __ ] de
nombreux la prochaine fois en tout cas
je tiens vraiment à encore une fois vous
remercier parce que c'est un châtiment
ab je me suis encore une petite frayeur
je m'en fais les frayeurs je vais finir
par au jardin sans rien c'est vraiment
vraiment important de vous remercier je
pense que chaque youtuber prend vraiment
une terrible importance à vous remercier
puisque c'est ce important tout
simplement c'est important de remercier
parce que sans ces [ __ ] c'est lourd
sans ces gens importants pas
on serait pas important nous non je
rigole mais oui c'est vrai que c'est là
je pensais faire de la merde pourquoi ça
pour s'envoyer lâché en train de
rechercher chaud je pleure à le may hamm
et voilà écoutez moi personnellement je
trouve ça très important de vous
remercier donc je vous remercie encore
mille fois au niveau des messages pré
youtube si vous payez genre je vais
juste vous demander une petite faveur de
la première à la dernière c'est de ne
plus m'en voyez des choses du genre est
ce que tu peux m'ajouter sur skype ou
sur la xbox est appelée de ça je peux
encore très bien comprendre n'y a pas de
souci les gens route patrick allemand
charles dallara dans le monde alors ok
mais vraiment c'est quelque chose qui
commence un peu à m'énerver de recevoir
sur les messages quotidiens que je
reçois sur trois quarts des messages
c'est les mêmes peux-tu m'ajuster sur
les bugs d'affichage acheté sur steam
comment as tu fait pour être connu alors
je me sens je me considérerai enfin
comme connu parce que vous peut-être
qu'à votre collège des fois vous parlez
moi ou je ne sais pas comme moi des fois
je parle de warcq que oui c'est quoi
nous apprécions ces pardons à votre fac
où je ne suis pas bon là où vous allez
en cours mais peut-être dans la rue
peut-être dans les poubelles mais non
vous êtes un booster serait ce la fac
une fac poubelle non sans rien mais
voulait c'est vrai que oh ouais mais tu
vois je
puisque je disais c'est vrai que yoann
au le trouve où un trou messieurs dames
peut encore plus gros de cette canette
de coca moins niais non sans rire c'est
bien ah [ __ ] tu oui oui mais là je me
rends pas vraiment compte que je suis
connue ou quoi de toute façon même si
pour moi je suis pas connu je fais
encore mes vidéos mais ça marche lieu où
tous les bus c'est clair et net ça
marche même plutôt bien je peux
m'estimer heureux le nombre de gens qui
font des vidéos maintenant est né ou à
écouter ça m'a parlé à dar fois que
jordan et on a commencé justement avant
le boom youtube isc l'amex et qui se la
pète caresse oui avant le boom du pubic
donc tu après la crise du public qui
étaient en 2011 un échec total devant
chez elle berne mais vraiment angoissé
j'ai commencé à la limite maintenant je
pense que c'est très dur de se faire
opérer au point mais justement éviter de
m'envoyer des messages pour vous
demander de la pub pour me demander mon
steam ou mon skate même si ça je réponds
parce que voilà faisait pas vraiment de
moyen de le savoir
skype abonnés caca et ça chez lui ça
fait qu'elle cache lui c'est parce qu en
fait j'étais fan de naruto
j'ai mixé et kakashi mon prénom lukas a
fait un truc totalement bio et j'assume
totalement d'ailleurs et c'est la fin de
la partie je crois non ah ouais ouais
c'est la fin et puis voilà donc éviter
de me demander de faire une vidéo avec
vous les gens s'il vous plaît je finis
vidéo avec qui je veux c'est pas la
peine de demander des fois j'aime bien
et je tombe sur des gens j'adore ce
qu'ils font et je proposerai des vidéos
avec eux par exemple goût ça a été le
cas à ou des choses comme ça enfin
feydeau et voilà c'est papa nous a
demandé de la pub de me demander de
faire une vidéo à avec vous de me
demander mon skype abonnés estime encore
ça je réponds ça je peux comprendre que
vous l'ayez pas donc ça laisse voulez
vous pouvez demander y a pas de souci je
répondrai mais au niveau voilà de
comment tu fais pour être connue est ce
que tu peux faire de la pub est ce que
je fais avec moi les gens sérieusement
le on n'est pas une part de lancement
pour être connu pour voir la pub
gratuitement comme ça même payant
d'ailleurs n'est jamais bon voilà en
tout cas j'espère que mes vidéos ne vous
décevront pas ne vous déçoivent pas ne
vous décevront jamais et à ne faisons
pas déçu même si dans le passé ça a
sûrement dû vous décevoir quand vous
voyez la première vidéo qui est
totalement nulle à chier
en tout cas les gens j'espère que halo
reach vous plaît ou en tout cas une plus
fortement et je vais pas su éduquer
dessus comme un gros porc après avoir
pris une gorgée de multifruits en
musique évidemment
[Musique]
ok c'était par une gorgée les 86 gorge
et n'a rien en tout cas les gens
j'espère que mes vidéos de goûter ce
vous parle on se retrouve pour un
bientôt d'ici quelques jours pour deux
autres vidéos spécial car depuis la
bonne et on use mais dont je suis fier
mais un pour 1 je suis pas tout seul
mais en fait on a trouvé un concept qui
était franchement marrant non comblés
deux nés à mme dans la vidéo mais vous
verrez que c'est c'est marrant tout cas
j'espère que ça vous plaira on se
retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo messieurs dames on va pencher sur
une troisième partie non c'est pas bien
accueillir et puis voilà les tient tout
le monde bat ya bientôt
encore merci pour tout votre soutien et
tout ça vous êtes vraiment géniaux et on
se retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos et peut-être d'autres projets
plutôt marrant pour les 58 j'ai ma
petite idée pour tout le monde
[Musique]
oui